well this particular trend goes contrary
to um the the wisdom being espoused by
people like
uh thundberg and aoc and
the the apocalyptic sect within the
environmentalist movement
there are a lot of smart
environmentalists who are making very
reasonable points
but the apocalypse within the the
environmentalist movement
are saying that we are going to lose
millions of people to climate change the
last
trend shows the number of people who die
as a result of natural disasters
these are not things that humanity has
any control over we are talking about
earthquakes and tsunamis and what we
have seen
and i kid you not and i urge people to
go to trent 10
is that the number of fatalities due to
environmental disasters
or environmental disasters has declined
by 99 percent of the last hundred years
trend nine i think people will be able
to believe this is real the long
piece that were actually the wars of the
of the last hundred years are are
winding down
in reality yes um
right now it's it's actually quite uh um
strange to talk about it now because we
do actually right now have a conflict
between two countries and that's
azerbaijan
and but what's so interesting about that
conflict
is that the two countries didn't
declare war on each other
and in fact i think that the last time
that a country declared war on another
was the korean war between
between the united states and north
korea
and in fact international conflicts
which is to say
two countries that declare war on each
other and then send armies across
borders to slaughter each other citizens
that has pretty much disappeared from
the world
what you have we've had an uptick in
recent years in in civil wars so pretty
much all the conflicts that are
happening in the world today
are civil wars they're no longer
international conflicts they're civil
wars
and there has definitely been an uptick
in civil wars
but nowhere close to the number of civil
wars that were taking place in 1970s and
the 80s
so even though yes we are not
at a at a historically
low level of conflict we are certainly
at a much level
lower level of conflict than we were in
the 70s and the 80s and that's why you
need the long-term data
because just when you think that things
are being bad
and that we've lived through some i
don't know five years of negative news
look what was happening in the world in
the 70s and 80s compare it and you'll be
happy
yeah and that brings us to trend number
10 which is that we are living in a
safer world than we have
in a very very long time
yes well this particular trend goes
contrary
to um
the the wisdom being espoused by people
like uh thumberg
and aoc and the the apocalyptic
sect within the environmentalist
movement there are a lot of smart
environmentalists
who are making very reasonable points
but the apocalypse
within the uh the environmentalist
movement
are saying that we are going to lose
millions of people to climate change the
last
trend shows the number of people who die
as a result of natural disasters
these are not things that humanity has
any control over we are talking about
earthquakes and tsunamis and what we
have seen
and i kid you not and i urge people to
go to trent 10
is that the number of fatalities due to
environmental disasters
or environmental disasters has declined
by 99
over the last 100 years why would that
be
one reason is that as we grow richer we
are able to build
more sturdy dwellings so as
architecture becomes more resistant to
earthquakes
flooding and so forth obviously fewer
people die
another thing that's improved is science
we have satellites which are able to
track the formation
of a storm in the caribbean we can
project
its trajectory along the coast of the
united states we can predict its
landfall within you know few dozens of
miles and all of that means is that we
gain time to prepare
for storms and hurricanes and tsunamis
well i'll get to tsunamis in a second
and therefore fewer people die even when
it comes to tsunamis
what we have now we are able to monitor
the ocean floor for earthquakes which
then
uh send information via sensors
to the mainland of japan saying for
example saying
that 200 kilometers to the east of
i don't know tokyo
yeah and you can expect a tsunami
in 36 minutes and that means that a lot
of people can
can can move to to higher ground or can
prepare or whatever
yeah all right so those were the the top
10 that you guys focus on in the book
now i'm going to really challenge you as
an author because i am going
to randomly flip to three more we will
finish with three more of the 78
and let's see if you know what you're
really talking about here so here we go
all right trend 52 rising natural gas
reserves
we've actually got extra gas i know
we've got a lot of wind bags out there
but we've got extra gas
that's right so before i go there
actually let me say that i don't
actually know
if tokyo is on on the seacoast or not
but never mind
we we're going to get i'm going to get a
lot of hate mail for that but when it
comes to
gas what happened was was extraordinary
and that is that
in the last 10 to 15 years
last 10 years uh shale fracking
has become much more efficient than
people ever assumed
and so a lot of natural gas that was
trapped in rocks
and you couldn't get to it we can now
get to
because of superior technology
that people decades ago didn't have and
so
the known reserves of natural gas
are now at a record level so in spite of
the fact that we've been using natural
gas
for decades we now know of
more reserves than ever before
that has the positive effect of course
of driving down the price of natural gas
when you have natural gas that is very
cheap
you can then use it instead of coal
generating electricity
when you use it instead of coal
generating electricity you are emitting
fewer co2 emissions into the atmosphere
so that is shale that is shell fracking
and we are very lucky that in the united
states we are the center
for some of the most innovative minds
because this is very much an american
success story
there you go all right i'm randomly
selecting here here we go
uh oh 41 this will be an interesting one
nuclear arsenals
are actually going down yes
so at the height of the cold war in the
mid 1980s the united states and the
soviet union
had something on the order of
uh 20 000 nuclear warheads each aimed at
one another if those
exploded at the same time it would be
over for civilization
the planet would have been uninhabitable
the end
what has happened since then uh is that
i believe we are down to about
3 000 nuclear warheads per soviet unit
per russia
and per united states so we have
decreased uh the amount
the number of warheads dramatically now
unfortunately in recent years there has
been some
backsliding on these international
treaties which are regulating how many
nuclear weapons a country can possess
and it's possible that in the future uh
the number of nuclear weapons possessed
by china
india united states russia and so forth
will start climbing and we should be on
top of this
it is a serious problem it is a serious
problem because the knowledge
that we have in terms of producing
nuclear weapons that cannot be
unlearned you can in a in a you know on
a shelf somewhere and hope
that people forget about it i think that
what we should be aiming for
is having the scientific community
tell us what would be the minimum number
of warheads
that could go off on earth whilst at the
same time
preserving civilization some semblance
of civilization preserving humanity
and then distribute that number of
warheads or access to those numbers of
warheads amongst nuclear powers so i
think we should be going in the opposite
direction
we should try to get nukes as low as
possible
and uh then have some sort of a uh
proportional distribution amongst great
powers
that would be a hell of a meeting trying
to get proportional distribution we've
done that before we've done that before
in the 1920s the united states presided
over uh the naval disarmament
between the united states uh france
britain and japan where there was a key
according to which uh naval warships uh
juggernauts were uh where uh sorry
juggernauts
dreadnoughts were distributed amongst uh
different great powers and uh i think it
was something like
10 10 7 7 4 4 depending on the power
of the relative power of of that great
power but my point is we have done this
before
with what was then the equivalent of a
nuclear weapon which was the dreadnought
ship if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversation about the
environment instead of non-stop yelling
check out our environment playlist and
if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell